manuel valls était en visite dans l'île
les 11 et 12 juin dernier une visite qui
a débuté par un dépôt de gerbe au
monument aux morts en présence des élus
locaux dont nassimah dindar présidente
du conseil départemental et didier
robert président du conseil régional
je suis concentré parce que c'est bien
essentiel que le suit à chaque fois sur
les attentes des français
ici nous sommes en france
elle part de la france par sa diversité
c'est au tour des dossiers de la réunion
le premier ministre s'est ensuite rendu
au port pour inaugurer une centrale
photovoltaïque dans l'enceinte du centre
pénitentiaire de manière symbolique
manuel valls a planté un bois de senteur
blanc un déplacement à la mairie du port
pour la signature du contrat de ville
qui s'est faite en présence de la 4ème
vice présidente du conseil départemental
sandra sinimalé dans ce défi mondial et
la réunion est incontestablement l'un
des lieux dont et d'une manière générale
avec la région s'engagent tous les
acteurs des cheveux les amphis des
retours dans le nord pour cette première
journée de visite avec la signature de
la convention canne planteurs et
usiniers sont enfin tombés d'accord tout
ceci en présence de la présidente du
conseil départemental nassimah dindar
vendredi a été la journée de la jeunesse
puisque des tables rondes ont permis aux
jeunes de faire des propositions sur les
thèmes aussi diverses que la sauvegarde
de la culture ou encore la lutte contre
les discriminations les conseillers
départementaux jeunes étaient eux aussi
présents à l'ancien hôtel de ville de
102 à un intervenant a tant que
représentant des jeunes et ce qui va se
passer bas on va plus parler d' actifs
des difficultés des jeunes de la
citoyenneté aussi de la discrimination
chaque jeune du cgj souhaitant
différents ateliers pour parler bas de
sujets différents l'accès aux loisirs
la discrimination et d'autres sujets et
donc assis sur le principe du mans ce
qu'a fait donc il sait pas y avoir de
préparation à l'avancé pour que nos
interventions soit spontané et compte
vraiment ce qu'on pense et moi la
citoyenneté est très importante car
c'est c'est la vie la sérénité si on
n'était pas dans un monde si qui avec
toutes ces règles
ça serait du n'importe quoi et il y a eu
un manque de citoyenneté en ce moment il
faut réagir les jeunes sont motivés pour
ça ils veulent rétablir les choses comme
il se doit une rencontre qui s'est
déroulée notamment en présence du
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports
patrick kanner manuel valls s'est
ensuite envolé pour mayotte